Ici, au Chili mon frère,
si tu n’as pas d’argent,
tu n’as pas accès à la santé.
Les manifestations au Chili,
c'est 26 morts en seulement
deux mois et demi.
Regardez comment ils nous répriment !
Je proteste
pour mon petit frère,
rien de plus.
Pour la génération qui vient après nous.
Au Chili, les droits humains
ont été bafoués massivement
et à grande échelle par l'État.
J'ai décrété l'État d'urgence.
C'est vraiment des scènes
de guérilla urbaines là,
qui sont en train de se dérouler
dans les rues de Santiago.
Ça y est, les policiers sont en train d'arriver.
Pour Brut, je vous emmène donc au Chili
pour essayer de comprendre pourquoi
la jeunesse là-bas se révolte.
Là-bas, là-bas, là-bas !
Ce mouvement de contestation
sociale au Chili,
en fait, il a démarré en octobre 2019
à cause de la hausse du prix du ticket
de métro à Santiago.
Le peuple uni
ne sera jamais vaincu !
Les étudiants et la jeunesse sont d’abord
descendus dans la rue
pour demander le retrait
de cette augmentation
et faire pression sur le gouvernement.
Mais rapidement, les revendications
de la population se sont transformées
en lutte contre la vie chère, contre la corruption
et contre les inégalités dans le pays.
Vendu !
Pour ça, pour ça !
Vendu pour pas grand-chose !
Si tu n'étais pas avec l'État,
tu serais avec nous, lâche !
Détruire les portiques du métro, les tickets,
c'était une réaction d'étudiants
qui en avaient marre... Marre !
...qu'on augmente les prix
et qu'on leur dise en plus :
"Levez-vous plus tôt, ne soyez pas faibles."
Parce que c'est aussi une rébellion
contre les mauvais traitements,
contre l'arrogance d'une élite
qui dit toujours :
"Si vous êtes pauvres,
c'est parce que vous êtes faibles."
Comme vous pouvez le voir derrière moi :
les forces de l’ordre ont bloqué
l’accès aux rues principales
qui mènent au cœur de la ville
depuis la place
et en fait, ils vont rester là
jusqu’à ce qu’ils décident de charger
et de vider la place.
Et allez ! P****n !
Ils sont violents leurs gaz lacrymos…
Wow !
T'inquiète pas,
ça va passer.
Sur la place, il y a maintenant plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes
et en fait, c’est uniquement dans
les rues adjacentes
qu’il y a des combats avec
les forces de l’ordre
et c’est à chaque fois quelques centaines
de personnes qui se battent avec eux.
Ça n'arrête pas depuis tout à l’heure.
Ils n’arrêtent pas d’envoyer des projectiles
sur la police.
Du coup, elle ne va pas tarder à charger,
ils sont en train de se reformer,
de reformer leurs rangs.
C’est parti, c’est parti, ça charge.
C’est allé très, très vite, la police a chargé,
ils ont réussi à arrêter quelques personnes
avant de se retirer immédiatement
parce qu’il y a énormément de manifestants
sur l’avenue centrale.
Enculés !
Fils de pute !
Nous, c’est le cœur qui parle,
c’est la rage.
Ici, au Chili mon frère, si tu n’as pas d’argent,
tu n’as pas accès à la santé.
Si tu n’as pas d’argent ici au Chili,
tu n’as rien, mon vieux.
Malheureusement, le fossé entre les riches
et les pauvres est visible ici.
On n'est pas les méchants.
Ce n’est pas nous les méchants.
Les méchants sont ceux
qui soutiennent l’énorme fossé
qu’il y a entre la réalité d’un pauvre
et celle d’un riche.
Parce que j’ai trois enfants,
parce que je suis un ouvrier
qui n’obtient que de la merde,
comme tous ces gens,
on ne gagne rien pendant qu’il y en a
qui gagnent deux fois plus,
trois fois plus que nous.
Ça ne peut plus durer.
On peut expliquer les manifestations
auxquelles on assiste aujourd'hui
en grande partie par
la constitution de 1980,
la constitution de la dictature
militaire du général Pinochet,
tout simplement parce que c'est
cette constitution qui a mis les bases
du système économique et social
actuel qui est fondé sur le néolibéralisme
et qui a largement privatisé et libéralisé
le système économique et social.
Et c'est cette jeunesse précarisée
qui se mobilise aujourd'hui,
parce qu'elle est née en démocratie et
parce qu'elle n'a plus peur de descendre dans la rue.
Je viens de m’écarter un peu de la manifestation
pour rejoindre un gars que
j’ai rencontré sur Instagram.
Il s’appelle Emile, c’est un jeune architecte
et il participe lui aussi aux manifestations,
mais à sa manière.
Donc on va aller voir dans son atelier
et vous allez vite comprendre pourquoi…
Ça, c’est un bouclier individuel.
Il s’ajuste ici
pour pouvoir être porté à une main.
- Je t’aide avec l’autre ?
- Oui.
On peut aussi le porter comme un sac à dos.
Et on peut les connecter les uns
avec les autres…
Pour qu’ils tiennent debout.
L’idée, c’est de permettre aux gens
qui font leur travail dans des endroits
dangereux, comme les secours,
de se sentir en sécurité.
Je pense que c’est un mouvement mondial
qu'a rejoint le Chili.
On a beaucoup appris de Hong Kong
pour manifester, nous protéger,
grâce aux vidéos qu’on a vues de là-bas.
Alors maintenant, on leur amène,
on attend qu'ils les utilisent.
Et on leur demandera si ça leur a servi
et ensuite, si ça a été efficace
contre les impacts de balles,
les gaz lacrymogènes et les canons à eau.
Ils étaient plutôt contents,
ils ont aimé le design
et ça nous rend heureux.
- Au revoir. Merci beaucoup.
Le soleil est en train de se coucher
mais il y a toujours autant de monde.
Là, il y a même des feux d’artifice
donc je pense que les gens
sont pas prêts de partir.
Où est le peuple ?
Le peuple est dans la rue
et il veut plus de dignité !
Les balles que vous nous tirez,
on vous les renverra.
All cops are bastards
Si les jeunes sont en colère,
c’est principalement contre le coût
de l’enseignement supérieur dans le pays
et pendant la manifestation,
cette colère, elle est allée très loin.
Les manifestants ont mis le feu
à une université
qui est en train de s’effondrer
On a besoin d'eau, vite !
Amenez la lance !
Là, clairement, il y a des manifestants
qui n'ont pas conscience du danger.
Y’en a encore qui essayent de passer
au travers de l’université
alors que les pompiers sont
en pleine intervention
et ça les met eux aussi en danger en fait
de devoir aller les chercher
pour leur dire : "Ne traversez pas !"
Elle vient de s’effondrer.
Les pompiers sont en train de maîtriser le feu,
il y a presque plus de flammes à l’intérieur,
on en voit encore un tout petit peu
dans la pièce principale.
Le Chili, c'est le pays où l'enseignement supérieur
est le plus cher de toute l'Amérique latine.
Il existe, certes, des bourses,
mais ces bourses-là servent à peine
à couvrir les frais universitaires.
Il n'y a pas au Chili
d'enseignement supérieur qui soit gratuit.
Même l'université publique est payante
et elle est extrêmement coûteuse.
Donc, ces bourses, elles ne servent
qu'à payer les frais d'inscription
mais le coût de la vie, lui-même,
il retombe encore une fois sur les familles.
Go !
Le niveau de violence
arrêtait pas de monter
pendant la manifestation
et c’est au milieu de ce chaos
que j’ai rencontré Adriel,
un jeune Chilien de 21 ans
qui vient toutes les semaines à Santiago
pour être en première ligne
de la contestation.
On veut manifester en paix et
c'est eux qui commencent à tirer.
C'est une crise sociale, à cause
des inégalités dans le pays.
C'est à cause de tout ça
et de notre président
qu'il y a une crise sociale.
Les gens sont fatigués de subir des abus.
Les personnes âgées sont en train de mourir,
parce qu’ils ne peuvent pas vivre
avec 120 € par mois.
Moi, par exemple, ma mère,
elle ne travaille pas en ce moment,
mais quand elle le fait,
son salaire n’est pas suffisant
pour faire vivre ses enfants.
Je ramène du citron de chez moi,
on doit tous prendre la moitié
d'un citron et le sucer
pour neutraliser les effets des gaz
lacrymogènes qui sont toxiques.
Les policiers ont même lancé
des gaz lacrymogènes
qui sont périmés depuis 2015, 2014,
et du coup, ils sont très, très forts.
C'est comme ça qu'on se défend,
on a juste des petits moyens.
De nombreuses personnes
ont subi des violences physiques,
notamment de la part des policiers,
et ont reçu des coups
et des gaz lacrymogènes sur le corps.
Beaucoup d'arrestations
ont été faites de façon arbitraire,
pour lesquelles
il n'existe pas de registre.
Il y a eu plus de 8000 arrestations.
C'est ma fille !
Lâche-la, connard !
Assassins !
Je suis en colère contre l’État,
contre les policiers chiliens,
mais je ne les place pas dans le même sac,
parce que j’ai connu des
agents de la police
qui sont des gens bien.
Mais là, je suis énervé à cause
de leurs actions contre nous
qui manifestons pacifiquement
alors qu’ils nous traitent
comme des délinquants.
Qui ne saute pas est policier !
Lorem ipsum dolor sit amet,
consectetur adipiscing elit.